le meilleur acteur dans un second rôle
et rédac était sûr de celui qu'avait que
ses premiers pas au cinéma dans un
prophète de jacques audiard en 2009 dans
hypo gratte reda kateb joue en interne
d'origine étrangère travaillant dans le
service qui perdent des clients médecine
campé par vincent lacoste
il est actuellement la fiche de loin des
jeunes ou des rideaux fun et on le
retrouvera le 8 avril dans l'astragale
aux côtés de leïla bekhti puis le 29
dans lost river de ryan gosling
bonsoir j'aurais jamais pensé me
retrouver sur cette scène un jeu vaut
effectivement le point de vue est
incroyable je suis très touché de
recevoir son césar du meilleur second
rôle
j'aime beaucoup les second rôles je
trouve que c'est les rôles qu'ils ont
cette chose collective de ce métier
d'acteur qui n'est pas pour prendre
toute la lumière
on se retrouve et forcément au centre
mais pour raconter des histoires porter
des projets être solidaire de quelque
chose qu'on a envie de défendre je vois
jean rochefort en face de moi qui avait
été mon parrain il ya quelques années
quand j'ai été pré nominés merci jean et
puis finalement bas et
c'est un acteur comme toi qu'on a envie
de ressembler quand on peut continuer
son parcours
et puis et puis du coup je voudrais
profiter de cette occasion pour partager
cette lumière et pour le coup d'être
placé au centre dans sept minutes pour
partager ce moment avec toute l'équipe
du film d'hippocrate vincent lacoste mon
cher confrère thomas lilti merci docteur
tous les acteurs techniciens figurants
qui ont participé de près au loin a dit
mme julie cas julie navarro pour le
casting elizabeth simpson mon agent qui
est une vrai partenaire est une
véritable ami le producteur de 31 juin à
neige vallée manuel barro toute l'équipe
du pacte qui nous offrait une belle
distribution pour ce film et puis et
puis bien sûr ma famille les absents
ceux qui sont là ceux qui arrivent
alessia mon adorait qui illumine ma vie
merci mon amour et mes amis qui sont là
depuis le début
je profiterai juste de cette occasion
pour un petit big up tout spécial à mon
pote lake qui m'avait aidé à remplir le
frigo à l'époque quand il était bien
vide je n'oublierai jamais voilà je veux
faire la chance d'être devant vous ce
soir
merci de confirmer cette chance merci